en este vídeo usaremos un clip para
formar una pequeña cola para nuestro
robot expand esto es con la que vamos a
formar le ayudará a reducir algo de la
fricción mientras se desplaza por el
piso es decir aumentar el desempeño de
nuestro robot así que toma un clip y
dobla lo hacia fuera ese pedazo que
doblas te lo cortas con las pinzas y vas
a intentar que la cola que formamos con
el clip encaje entre los dos
interruptores a una distancia que rebase
el estuche de batería pero que no rebase
los motores es decir que quede un poco
fuera de la estrecha de batería pero que
no tenga la misma distancia que los
motores al suelo esto va a ayudar a que
se arrastre mejor por el piso entonces
una vez que lo doblas te y encaja
perfectamente entre los dos
interruptores puedes ajustarlo y
doblarlo a la altura que mejor quede
para que tenga un mejor desplazamiento
el robot es pot
y una vez que abrí waste ya como
doblarlo y qué altura debe llevar tomas
la pistola y pone silicon sobre la cola
ahora también puedes aprovechar para
poner silicon sobre el cable amarillo y
así éste también se mantenga en su lugar
ahora pon mucho silicon sobre la cola
del robot para que de esta forma te
asegures de que se mantenga en su lugar
y deja que enfríe
ya que el silicon en frío veamos si
funciona mejor
en efecto ya funciona mejor puedes ver
que el robot spot ya funciona un poco
mejor pero sigue teniendo un poco de
fallas sigue necesitando un poco de
ayuda en ocasiones con los interruptores
pues no siempre se da la vuelta cuando
debe así que en el siguiente vídeo
veremos si podemos hacer que el robot
staudt tenga un mejor desempeño y que al
chocar con nuevos obstáculos los
interruptores respondan y el robot
export se dé la vuelta como debe hacerlo